hello good evening we begin with some
breaking news and a British man who
worked at the UK Embassy in Berlin has
admitted spying for Russia prosecutors
say David Valentine Smith was motivated
by an intense hatred of Great Britain
and that he'd wanted to hurt the UK
well let's talk to our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes and
Deborah dispute from his legal team
about his motivation here
yes his lawyer is saying that he didn't
intend to do harm to the UK but it's a
pretty extraordinary story he has
admitted to eight charges under the
official Secrets act he was a security
guard at the British Embassy in Berlin
and the details that have come out at
the Old Bailey show the allegations that
were made by the prosecutors in terms of
the charges against him about how he had
contact with the Russian military
attache in Berlin and how he had passed
on
um sentiment information including the
identities of civil servants working at
the embassy secret documents as well
that were passed over to this Russian
officer and then he was finally detained
last August and brought back to the UK
where he has faced these charges and the
actual here ring was last week but they
it can only be reported today because
the prosecutors have decided not to go
ahead with a ninth charge that was
disputed
um and so now this individual this
former security guard is facing a
maximum sentence of 14 years for spying
we don't know yet
um what his punishment will be
um but a significant
um development given relations between
the UK and Russia they have been so low
for so long so uh really extraordinary
that uh British citizen decided to do
this